hibernation is a concert we're very
familiar with
many sci-fi stories require cyber nation
to work
while imaginations have been running
wild in pop culture the science of
hibernation and a shorter state called
torpa have been lagging behind
now this is changing
an array of potential medical benefits
is driving scientists from labs around
the world to search for the underlying
mechanisms of this new magical state
to travel for centuries for millennia
that
way or out of our reach at the moment
but fibonacci could breed you from a
condition in which you could not live
any longer to one which you may still
live
as well as helping to buy time for
people on the waiting list for an organ
a synthetic form of hibernation could
also possibly offer protection against
radiation to cancer patients and space
travelers
there are serious experiments that have
been done
there are significant and serious
results that have been produced so i
would say it's not science fiction
anymore now is the moment yes now we at
least have a pot in front of us of
research but that we know could live
there
[Music]
turpo is the actual state in which our
metabolism the energy we use drops to a
minimum so it is a suspended animation
state
many episodes of torpor one after the
other interrupted by a brief very brief
arousal that's what makes hibernation
[Music]
we have bats that go into hibernation
bears
rodents
primates
some animals can enter brief episodes of
torpor
you'll be surprised how many answers get
thrown away because they're on your
finger dead but actually they're just
interpol
while it might not be something that
humans do hibernation or torpor is
common in species across the many orders
of mammals
this might mean that the genes involved
in triggering and controlling these
states were present in our common
ancestor who needed a survival strategy
when we first as mammals appear on this
planet
we were hunted by something about this
size even a bit smaller so this is
actually an herbivore to be honest but
just imagine like a giant ostrich or
even a turkey that were velociraptor and
mini raptor
our ancestors developed a new ability
generating heat within our own cells
instead of relying on an outside source
like the sun
that helped them hunt at night when
dinosaurs were less active
but generating energy to maintain the
body's temperature requires resources
which might have been often hard to come
by
[Music]
the idea to turn off
the heater turn off the unnecessary
energy use that your body
requires even when we're resting
is an energy saving and a life-saving
strategy
there's nothing you're doing in this
state besides surviving
you're bridging
a time in which you
couldn't be alive because there was no
food or water or whatever resources you
needed get very very near that
without touching that impenetrable wall
unlike sleep in a state of torpor the
physiology of an animal changes
completely
the majority of cells that produce or
use energy simply stop and as a result
the body's temperature goes down and its
oxygen consumption decreases
the kidneys shut down as they don't need
to expel nitrogen and with no food to
process the gastrointestinal tract
changes
muscle and bones enter a resting stage
but don't lose their strength
with a breath drawn every minute or so
the heart is barely beating pumping just
enough blood to keep vital organs alive
and the most energy consuming organ the
brain also changes its rhythm
we don't need the brain during thorper
pretty much the synapses get reabsorbed
meaning neuron will withdraw your
handshake and then talk way less to each
other so they speak with different
rhythm and
those rhythm during torpor are the same
rhythm we use when we are awake or at
least they very much resemble their
intense activity that we when we use
when we are awake but much much slower
is a slow wakefulness if we allowed me
to pass this term
let's say it's like watching a movie and
we see the frame of this movie
going slower and slower progressively
and
at the end we just stick with one single
picture
terpor is
very very different from sleep
from coma from general anesthesia from
any behavior we think about like resting
or inactivity we're not even sure that
torpor is resting the body needs to
recover from torpor after torpor
after the dinosaurs disappeared mammals
took over the world and many species
lost this once life-saving ability
but restoring it presents an exciting
possibility
hibernation interpreter is something
hidden within our genetic code and
within our brain regulation probably and
we think that today we have lost maybe
the ability to initiate this behavior
because we didn't need it for a long
time
but we are trying to discover what is
the ignition kit
here at one of the oldest universities
in the world mateo chiri is a professor
of physiology
in 2013 he and his team were the first
to induce what he calls synthetic torpor
in an animal that doesn't naturally
enter this state a rat
it was just by accident i
worked before on metabolism and the idea
was to increase metabolism to lose
weight one day we just try to see what
could happen if we were actually
shutting down metabolism we block we
inhibit a small group of neurons in a
very old region of the brain called
raphopalydus
the raphepalidus is a very interesting
area of the brainstem it controls a lot
of our body function heart rate body
temperature a respiration breathing so
it's the area we use to defend ourselves
from the cold it makes you breathe
faster because you need more oxygen to
sustain heat production we were sure if
we were stopping that flow of
information we could see it or
and yes we did the first experiment
worked and it was very lucky it never
happened the first time
still one of the happiest moment in my
professional life
[Music]
with this thermo camera we can record
the temperature of surface
coolest is blue and black
red and white is warmer
[Music]
using drugs to switch off this part of
the brain the team bring the animal in
and out of a torpor-like state just like
natural torpor the animal's temperature
drops and a period of inactivity follows
[Music]
once the animal is brought out of it
it's as though nothing happened
scientists have now found even more ways
of inducing this state artificially and
many teams are investigating the body's
adaptations during torpa
in germany a team led by walter
tinganelli is using a particle
accelerator to further this research
[Music]
we try to understand the molecular
mechanism behind the hibernation itself
so we try to simulate in vitro so on
cells
cell culture
the physiological change at which the
cells are during hibernation
a complex process like topper can't be
simply induced in a petri dish but the
team can simulate its conditions on a
cellular level
we perform experiment changing the
oxygen concentration of the cells
changing the metabolism of cells for
example producing starvation on cells or
changing the temperature of course
although this research into hibernation
relies on cutting-edge science its
foundations can be traced back decades
the most important experiment with the
hibernators they happened around the
sixth when the first human space mission
starts with apollo 11 of course they
take the astronauts on the moon in 1969
because the physiological change that
happened in natural laborators are very
interesting for space
[Music]
and then what the researcher find out
was that the radio resistance of an
animal during hibernation increases
but then the idea was okay but if human
cannot hibernate why we should continue
this kind of experiment such experiment
and then the the the interest let's say
on the iberonation was fading a little
bit
developments in the past decade have
revived interest in the resistance to
radiation while in torpa
the team at gsi is particularly
interested in how this could one day be
harnessed in radiotherapy for cancer
patients
you want to kill the tumor and spur the
lte tissue if you can bring the patients
in synthetic aberration then first of
all most probably you will stop the
tumor grow but then if you are also able
to reduce the healthy tissue damage and
to treat with let's say a higher than
today dose this could be in future
perhaps a very nice tool and we try to
understand if this process increase the
radio resistance just in the healthy
tissue and not in the tumor tissue
and so a few times a year cancer cells
in a state of simulated synthetic torpor
like these taken from a mouse are put
into one of gsi's caves
these are rooms where outlets from the
particle accelerator lead and so the
cells are irradiated with heavy ions
here is where we put our flask
with cells you do not shoot a
radioactive particle you just shoot a
ion so it's an atom without some
electrons
and then this does a certain damage
especially at the end of its track
along the lines where the ions have
pierced the cell the molecules
highlighted in green are trying to mend
the damaged dna
torpo doesn't stop cell damage but one
theory is that the repair might be
carried out more smoothly that cell is
not really working because it's
interpreted it's like if you had to fix
a car that broke it would be much harder
to fix a car while the engine was
running while the car was running and
that's why we think
cells in torpor are better at deal with
radiation damage
[Music]
after irradiation the team analyzes how
many cells survive and which genes were
involved
then you can play with these cells
changing uh for example silencing
specific gene and then to understand
which of these genes are very important
for the synthetic hibernation process
for increasing the radio resistance so
playing with all these different tools
we will be able to understand as much as
possible about this
very complex process
gsi's ability to bombard cells with
heavy ions also has applications for
space radiation one of the main problems
agencies like issa and nasa need to
overcome for human exploration of the
solar system
in space the most dangerous radiation
are essentially particles so 70 percent
are protons very energetic protons but
then you have a lot of ions up to uh to
the iron so that really hits the
astronaut like a small
projectile
during a long voyage to mars synthetic
torpor could offer added protection not
only from radiation but also from loss
of bone and muscle strength
and there would be other practical
benefits
no need for extra food or to mitigate
the stress of prolonged isolation
and as the team continues to observe the
impact of torpor on the body and mind
there could also be clues as to how we
tackle and perhaps even reverse other
forms of degeneration here on earth
in the brain during purple
some markers start to appear
what i'm saying with marker marker our
indication that something usually is
wrong we use marker to identify diseases
one of those markers is a hallmark
of alzheimer's disease the brain of a
squirrel
in turbo will drastically resemble the
brain of an alzheimer patient we could
say hibernation is diving is a dive in
dementia
what is interesting is that when animals
arouse from turbo and hibernation their
brain very quickly return to normal
synapses get reformed in stronger number
eventually some evidence suggests that
the brain works even better after torpor
the arousal from torpor is neurotrophic
storm to be honest it's the most intense
neural plasticity i ever seen the brain
is really rewiring
could we exploit and understand what is
the mechanism behind this extreme
intense plasticity and apply it to
neurodegenerative disorder or could we
manipulate memories or neural trace or
behavior that we have learned like
addiction and kind of prevent themselves
to be rewired this is all unknown but
it's quite possible
with trial so far only done in rodents
there are still questions to be answered
before moving forward
during natural hibernation animals have
to come out of torpor occasionally and
we don't know why we also still don't
know how long a synthetic torpor could
last safely and if humans would need to
be bought out of the state periodically
as well
all of this means that getting to the
stage of human clinical trials won't be
easy
my feeling is that if we ever gonna
reach the phase of testing it in human
it will be on
some patient that is really in a very
critical condition something that has no
treatment at all and is uh that is
looming and there is no way out of that
someone on the waiting list for
transplant could be the case a very
aggressive cancer could be another case
but even if synthetic torpor and
hibernation can one day save lives and
perhaps even smooth out our road to the
stars there are still many ethical
questions that will need answers
what's the status of a human in a
synthetic torpor for a long time let's
say you stay for a year or two what if
you get divorced by your partner during
interpret to be woken up who has the
right to wake you up
what if the stock market collapsed what
if you were charged with crimes what if
you were convicted and then you wanna
spend your time in prison in synthetic
turbo
so there are plenty of ethical
implications
this research is still the domain of
academia but private investment might
not be too far away
some private company space related
companies i'm sure they are interested
in that because even in conferences
sometimes they come to my colleagues
they would like to know more which stage
we are and so on something like
okay is interesting but let's leave them
do let's say the dirty job now
and then if we recognize that in the end
something good can
come out from that perhaps we will jump
on it
the way research is structured today you
have to compete with your colleague to
get funding this is slowing science down
and slowing innovation down and i'm
afraid of this switching in the focus of
research from public university or from
university in general to the private
sector my baby that's the way it was
gonna go
i'm just worried that some critical
technology could be
owned
and therefore
used as a mean to power eventually
you